well when I started my graduate work in
genetics the big question was what on
earth is this gene how can it do these
amazing things that it does and it was a
complete mystery
that was a big question that was the new
question that attracted me to genetics
and that made me want to spend my life
trying to get an answer or to get part
of the answer by at that time a lot was
known about how genes are transmitted in
heredity and some of the things that
they control but nothing was known about
the physical or chemical structure that
was responsible for what the gene could
do and it seemed very inaccessible and
very hard to get at and and that was the
the question that was mostly on my mind
to find a way to work that would help to
decide what the gene was like and what
it was how it could do what it was doing
I was working with bacteria a bacteria
had become a very good material to work
with for genetics because in 1943 while
I was a graduate student for the first
time it became clear that bacteria had
genes like other organisms before that
the bacteria bacteriologists were
telling us that bacteria just changed
with the environment when it was
established that they had regular genes
and they can be used for genetic
experiments that's when I decided that I
wanted to work with bacteria I was just
beginning the research for my PhD and I
had planned to do it with the fruit fly
which was the standard organism in
genetics and a wonderful little bug and
I was going to try to understand how
radiation induces mutations and in a
fruit fly Drosophila when I read that
paper proving that bacteria have genes I
really got excited and thought that
would be a wonderful material to work
with I mean they multiplied every 20
minutes
and you can hold a billion of them in a
little test tube and so just think how
many generations you can work with in
very short time so that's when my
advisor at Columbia professor dobzhansky
saw how excited I was about this new
development using bacteria for genetics
he suggested that I might want to do my
PhD research with e.coli instead of
discipline and that's why he sent me to
Cold Spring Harbor for the summer and to
learn how to work with bacteria Lauria
and elbrick were the ones who had
discovered that bacterial genes and they
were going to be there it called spring
haba that summer and so I did go and
that was one of the most fortunate
events in my working life that that I
connected was Cold Spring Harbor because
it turned out I actually stayed there
for 11 years I haven't caught a
beginner's luck I think the very first
experiment I did I had no idea what I
was doing I the director at the
laboratory at Cold Spring Harbor handed
me a culture of e.coli test tube and he
pointed to an ultraviolet lamp and said
go do me induce mutations so I had to
sort of feel my way about how to work
with these bugs I watched other people
and so what how they worked and I
started my very first experiment and the
first thing I needed to do was to decide
what dose of ultraviolet light to use
because they were no published there was
no published information about that so I
was stabbing in the dark at the first
try and in my first try I overdid the
dose I used doses much too high and the
next day when I looked at my petri
dishes I found that I had put a million
bacteria on the surface of each of them
and the next day nobody grew there was
nothing on any of the plates except one
petri dish
had four colonies growing on it so for
bacteria out of the million that I had
put on a petri dish had somehow survived
this very high dose and it occurred to
me that maybe those four were mutants
resistant to radiation
because in Co Spring Harbor at that
point there was a lot of talk about
resistance doctor demerits was working
on resistance to penicillin which had
just been discovered and there was
resistance to this that and the other
that people were working on and so I
thought well maybe there and why did
they survive Despero bacteria out of
millions and I cultured them and tested
them and sure enough they could
withstand at least a hundred times more
radiation both ultraviolet light and
later we found also x-rays than the
parent strain it turned out to be a clue
to a whole new area that I was just
starting to work on and it led me to
understanding that ultraviolet light
does a lot more than just induce
mutations it activates what we know we
now know to be 43 G's at least 43
different genes in E coli that are quiet
and silent when it cell is healthy but
are suddenly activated and start turning
out their product when the DNA is
damaged by radiation or some other
agents my first mutation sort of led me
into perceiving that this was going on
and it was a discovery of what we call
the SOS response in e.coli which implies
that it's a life-saving mechanism which
is indeed because of the activities that
are turned on by these genes that are
activated by the damage promote the
repair of the damage and the survival of
the cell in a variety of different ways
and the survival of the
population actually and I think that my
experience in call Spring Harbor was
what sort of softened me up to think in
terms of repair because one of the
people I met in Cold Spring Harbor was a
scientist named Barbara McClintock who
won the Nobel Prize in her 80s I think
for the amazing work she did in genetics
it was a pleasure to get to know her and
one of the things I remember best about
being in Cold Spring Harbor was many
times that I spent in Barbara
mclintock's laboratory looking over her
shoulder and watching her work when she
was making her major discovery when she
found that genes actually can move from
one location to another
this was very revolutionary we always
thought that the chromosome was very
stable and genes stay put
but she showed that they can jump and
they can have important effects when
they do and anyway one of the things
that Barbara was working on and she
talked about this at our at our meetings
at Cold Spring Harbor she was studying
how chromosomes joined together when
they broke it because chromosomes can
break as a result of various treatments
and when they do she noticed that they
come together very rapidly the broken
ends join and she was very puzzled about
how that could work but she did make a
point of saying that they could find the
broken ends could find each other over a
long distance very completely different
parts of the nucleus they would sort of
aim at each other there was a seem to be
a force that was bringing them together
and since genes around chromosomes and
chromosomes are being repaired when
they're broken it seemed to me that they
must be some molecular kind of repair
going on inside the chromosome that
would have involved repairing
the jeans so I think that exposure to
the way broken chromosomes are repaired
made me think in terms of repair when I
was considering what was happening and
irradiated bacteria before the DNA is
damaged let's say by radiation the DNA
is quietly replicating itself copying
itself and when DNA is damaged by
ultraviolet light for instance which
changes one of the elements of the DNA
and stops the replication the enzymes
that are copying the DNA cannot get by
that damaged spot so the whole thing
stops and that's lethal if nothing
happens because if the replication is
stopped and there's nothing that comes
restart it that's the end of that cell
but we've learned later that B coli and
all cells including human cells have
developed repair mechanisms that can in
various ways take care of that damage
and get rid of it one way or another
there are a number of different ways to
do it and usually they work very
efficiently and the damage just goes
away and the replication continues and
that happens and as I say in a number of
ways for instance if you shine visible
light on the e.coli after it's been
damaged by ultraviolet that will take
care of getting rid of the damage the
visible light splits that lump that's
sitting on the DNA and makes it go away
so that's an immediate repair and then
there's another repair mechanism that's
called the cut and patch mechanism
actually excision repair which detects
the damaged spot cuts one strand of the
DNA on one side of the damaged cuts on
the other side and thereby removes a
small piece of the DNA containing the
damage and that leaves a gap see DNA has
two strands
so there's one strand that's still
intact and the other one has a piece
taken out of it by this cut and patch
mechanism and then another enzyme comes
along and fills in that patch using the
information on the other strand to do it
accurately so that's another repair
mechanism that acts very quickly and
that takes care of most of the damage
that happens but sometimes there's a
kind of damage that cannot be easily
repaired by these mechanisms and that's
where the SOS response happens so here
you have damage sitting on the DNA which
see if there's a bolide couldn't help
and the cut and patch couldn't help for
some reason and then what happens is the
stalled replication the place where the
replication has stopped generates a
signal that says SOS basically and then
a number of things happen and I can't
really describe them in great detail but
the two strands of DNA come apart into a
sort of a bubble and that's the signal
for the SOS system is single stranded
DNA which normally doesn't occur and
they happily replicating DNA but the
single strands bubbling out cause
another molecule to come and find those
single strands and that sets off a
sequence which leads to turning on 43
teams you know there were a lot of
people involved that I haven't mentioned
other people but the SOS response was a
a joint work and this was a young man
his name was Miroslav Rodman he was a
postdoctoral fellow in Harvard and I had
written a paper in which I suggested
that ultraviolet light was inducing two
different consequences in a similar way
that sounded as if they were being
induced together
and radmann few years later had linked
to other ultraviolet effects and
suggested that they were both induced by
the same signal and one of them was the
same one that I had linked so we we both
linked a I had linked it to be and he
had linked it to C and when we met I
guess it was in 1972 he had just
described his end of this and so we met
and we put together in this observation
that I had linked to events that were
caused by UV and said that they were
induced together and he had linked to
others and one of them was the common
one so there we had three different
ultraviolet effects that we thought were
induced in a common way by a single
signal and that was really the beginning
and by the way radmann was the one who
introduced the term SOS and it was used
in the sense of the International
distress signal so in a way our putting
together our two separate pieces of this
again the SOS response to be appreciated
it was a great joy to be part of the
group that was working on DNA repair I
mean it was a small international group
they must have been probably I'd say 30
or 35 individual scientists and a group
of students around them and so on who
we're trying to understand how the DNA
changes and how its repaired and and all
of that and being part of that group was
one of the most joyful experiences I
ever had in science because it was a
group of people with a very common set
of goals and I sometimes hear these days
that there's a lot of competitiveness in
science it doesn't ring a bell with the
way it was in my experience at all we've
shared our information we shed our
strains we
cheered for each other when somebody
made an important discovery and it was a
human experience that was extremely
satisfying and when I look back on my
work that that's a big part of why I'm
glad I did science
you